richard sherman potential hall of famer
some would say likely hall of famer
decade of work and he's been a great
player entered the league as a low round
pick in 2011 established himself in 2012
we all became aware of him
with his umad bro picture in tom brady's
face after the seahawks beat the
patriots that year
and became a keep member of the legion
of boom negotiated his own deal three
years ago with the 49ers
now acting as those in agent again he's
waiting for that phone
to ring he said on the chris
collinsworth podcast it's been in slow
motion so far
the saints reportedly have interest in
richard sherman
you know he it it's not going to be easy
to get what he's looking for no one's
going to pay you for what you've done in
the past
the question is what are they going to
pay you for what they think you'll do in
the future and is it enough
to get you to say i'll keep playing
that's really going to be the question
for richard sherman
yeah and because he's going to be 33 at
the end of the month
and i think that right now basically
whenever
you're talking about veterans in this
league it's going to be a depressed
market for them and we've seen some
cornerbacks get
some money but i don't really know that
anybody's gotten like
big big time money in free agency right
now and especially given what in
with the injury history that richard
sherman has and he played only five
games in 2020
i don't know exactly what he's looking
for but he's probably not going to
receive top dollar
as somebody who is you know in his mid
30s
and only played five games last year i i
think it makes a lot of sense
that his market is slow right now and
really it might
be best for him to maybe even wait until
after the draft to see
what teams really still have a need at
quarterback i mean
i feel like that just might be the way
it works out mike i don't know
exactly where his market is right now
miles this is something i said before
free agency began and specifically
before the pre-free agency negotiating
window opened at some point within the
last couple of weeks i said that
if robert sala the new jets coach who
was the defensive coordinator during the
entirety
of richard sherman's time in san
francisco if
salah is not at the front of the line to
sign robert to sign richard sherman
that is the reddest flag that possibly
could fly
about whether or not anyone else should
be at the front of the line
to sign richard sherman because as salah
is trying to
get his system in place get his way
up to speed if he's not putting an arm
around richard sherman saying i need you
with me
that that's that screams out to me
beware
uh and uh uh that's all i'll say about
that
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports